certains crient au coup d'état alors que
d'autres y voient un espoir en la
tunisie et à tabac stade i townley raïs
est due à son statut d'homme viril demos
a adapté au coma hier à sous marie
sauteraud kuma war ou à la haine ou seul
chez moi c'est un coup de théâtre qui
prend la jeune démocratie tunisienne
englué dans une crise économique
sanitaire et politique vendredi 25
juillet le président à geler les travaux
du parlement est prise en main le
pouvoir exécutif quelles raisons ont
bien pu pousser cali sayyed a limogé le
chef du gouvernement et suspendre le
parlement est il vraiment pertinent de
parler de coup d'état ou faut-il y voir
un sursaut républicain
réponse dans facture
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre revenons un peu en
arrière 25 juillet jour de la fête de la
république
des centaines de personnes dont beaucoup
de jeunes se rassemblent à tunis devant
le parlement tunisien et dans plusieurs
grandes villes pour exprimer leur colère
contre le gouvernement exaspérés
chamailleries entre les partis au
parlement qui paralyse les décisions
dans le pays le peuple veut la
dissolution du parlement changement de
régime voici quelques-uns des slogans
que l'on peut entendre durant ces
manifestations la tunisie en fait tu
connais un bras de fer très important
entre le président de la rfec il est
rached ghannouchi et le président de la
république donc le bras de fer est
gagnée depuis
et le résident de ma mère est accusée
d'outrepasser se fondre dans le sillage
de ces très forte mobilisation le
président kaïs ayed a donc annoncé qu'il
gelait les activités du parlement et des
mets tes de ses fonctions le chef du
gouvernement et shane michi ce qui
légalement est rendue possible par
l'article 80 de la constitution
tunisienne en cas de péril imminent
menaçant les institutions de la nation
et la sécurité et l'indépendance du pays
et entravant le fonctionnement régulier
des pouvoirs publics le président de la
république peut prendre les mesures
nécessitent et par cette situation
exceptionnelle après consultation du
chef du gouvernement et du président de
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
et après en avoir informé le président
de la cour constitutionnelle
problème toutes les conditions n'étaient
toutefois pas réunies d'où les
accusations de coup d'état par certains
utilisaient article 82 la constitution
jeune alice en fait sont pas d'accord
entre eux car ils n'auraient pas
respecté pour certaines autres parties
de cet article 81 ou et d'autres saints
de radio le président de la lfp et du
chef du gouvernement et en informer la
cour constitutionnelle le texte
désignant les membres donc en fait là
constitutionnel depuis plusieurs mois
ce n'est pas un hasard calista liait à
opérer ce coup de force qui a d'ailleurs
été saluée par beaucoup de tunisiens et
même l'un de formule 1 les plus
puissants du pays
et lui en 2019 sur fond de ras-le-bol de
la classe politique et promettant de
lutter contre la corruption cet
universitaire n'a pourtant jamais caché
ses critiques du régime parlementaire et
des compromis partisans qu'ils exigent
le 25 juillet et renforce sa base
électorale il répond à des attentes et
qui sont très claires et le 25 juillet
au soir plusieurs sièges de partis
ennahdha ont été brûlées par exemple
défendre le pays contre l'entrisme
islamistes c'est en effet l'une des
raisons qui pourraient expliquer
l'opération coup de force du président
queille sayed et nadal le principal
parti d'opposition d'inspiration
islamiste est particulièrement pointée
du doigt depuis son retour sur la scène
politique en 2019 après six ans
d'absence et cristallise une partie du
mécontentement de la population
la population exploser un ras-le-bol de
nada la manière dont artilleurs pu gérer
les affaires lorsqu'ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir ça bien aller pour les canadiens
méritent le
détour ne serait
pas
tarie
[Musique]
couplé à cet immobilisme politique la
très mauvaise santé économique et social
de la tunisie depuis plusieurs années
rend la situation tout simplement
explosive la tunisie négocie
actuellement un quatrième plan daide en
dix ans auprès du fonds monétaire
international et a subi de plein fouet
la chute du tourisme donc c'est dans ce
contexte là le bon timing et économique
le contexte du collier de mac
anticipation de la prise de la ceni et
des hôpitaux dans un état lamentable et
avec un état qui est à genoux
économiquement vie d'articulation
supputations qui le tour du dinar s'est
effondré il ya une réelle crise réelle
crise économique et des effectivement de
l'eucoco vide a ajouté un seul revers
mise en lumière des problèmes du pays
notamment comment il ya plus d'oxygène
dans les hôpitaux chômage profondément
rationner inflation continue dégradation
des infrastructures publiques
dix ans après les soulèvements des
printemps arabes tous les facteurs à
l'origine de la révolution de 2011
continue de plomber la tunisie après un
changement de régime aussi fort ou
auquel personne ne s'attendait c'était
normal qu'il y ait une zone de
turbulences et maintenant et bien cet
accueil sayed de résoudre l'équation
politique et de rétablir les activités
du parlement le plus rapidement possible
l'urgence est donc à la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement qui sont à négocier
avec plusieurs partenaires culmont pays
revienne à une situation plus stable et
commune tout au moins sur l'astre est
positive le pays a les ressources
nécessaires en termes destitution de
compétences donc l'état est
effectivement dans une situation très
critique mais les administrations sont
là c'est plutôt un indicateur positif
une semaine après le coup de force du
président des députés très critique
envers kaïs sayed ont été arrêtée
faisant craindre une dérive autoritaire
dans le pays la tunisie reste pourtant
un pays qui suscitent l'espoir lui qui
est souvent considéré comme le seul
ayant réussi sa révolution démocratique
au moment des printemps arabes